The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
So, good afternoon.
Continuing our story
about networks,
what we've seen
so far is a story
where you have a
network that you're
trying to connect computers
to communicate together.
And we use a network
with switches
arranged in some topology
to allow us to find
paths between computers.
And so we looked at
the routing problem.
We looked at two different
routing protocols
to solve that.
Earlier, we talked
about this idea
of a packet-switched
network and there are queues
in packet-switched networks.
And when traffic comes in too
fast, and the queues overflow,
packets may get dropped.
We also looked before at links
which have errors on them.
And so if you have
errors on links,
then your coding scheme
isn't able to correct
for those errors,
packets may get lost.
And when we looked at
shared media networks
with MAC protocols,
depending on the MAC protocol
you use, you may
collisions, which means
that packets may get lost.
So what you have is a
packet-switched network that
has the property of something
called a best-effort network.
And what "best effort"
means is that the network
has a few properties that
you have to cope with.
The first property of
a best-effort network
is that packets may get lost.
The second problem in a
best-effort issue that
arises in a best-effort network
is that packets have delays,
but the delays are variable.
And particular queuing delays
that happen in switches
are variable delays.
The good property of a
packet-switched network
is that each packet is treated
independently by the network.
So it could be that you
have a stream of packets
you want to send, say, belonging
to a video stream or a file.
And the sender sends them
in some sequential order,
but these packets may
take different paths
through the network.
And in fact, there may be
switches in the network,
for whatever reason, that may
not treat packets in first
in, first out order.
They may reorder packets.
But more generally, packets
may take different paths
through the network because the
routing protocol might decide
to change the paths on you, and
so packets make get reordered.
And the fourth issue in
a best-effort network
is that, in fact, packets
may get duplicated.
So you may have the same
packet show up multiple times
even though it was sent only
once for a bunch of reasons.
One of them is that
there could be problems
in the implementation of
the switches or the nodes
that cause packets
to get duplicated.
But it could also
be that you may
have a link with a
high packet loss rate,
or this may be a
shared medium where
you have a MAC protocol
that has collisions.
So you may have a
retransmission protocol--
let me try to resend the packet
a few times at the lowest layer
over a shared medium or a link.
And sometimes, multiple
versions of the multiple copies
of the same packet
may get through.
And we'll actually understand
why that happens more today.
So packets may get duplicated.
So in a way, a packet-switched
network like the internet
is great because it's
very easy to build.
And the reason it's easy
to build in some sense
is because about the
only property that you're
providing from the
design of the network
is to tell the endpoints, oh, I
might get your package through.
There's no guarantees
on anything.
As long as there's some
non-zero probability
of getting a packet through
from one endpoint to the other,
that's pretty much all
it takes to declare
that you have a conforming
best-effort network.
So it's easy to build.
But of course, it means that you
have all these issues that you
want to deal with
if you actually
want to run applications.
So as an example of
an application is,
let's say you are
trying to download
a web page, or a set of web
pictures and text on a page.
What you would like
is an abstraction
that you can implement some sort
of a scheme you can implement
in the network or in between
the endpoints that makes it
so that an application sends
a bunch of bytes or packets
or sends a message.
And at the receiving side,
you get those bytes reliably.
So that's what we're
going to understand today.
We're going to look at
today and next week, we're
going to look at
how to implement
a protocol that provides
reliable data transport.
And the ideas we're
going to look at
are probably the ideas
that are in the world's
most popular computer program.
It's the most popular
in that it runs
in the most number of places.
And it's a protocol
called TCP, which
stands for the Transmission
Control Protocol.
Now, we're not going through
all the gory details of TCP.
We're going to look
at a simplified
version of this protocol.
So maybe it's TCP-lite.
But it'll cover the
main idea of how
you can achieve reliability.
And this particular program runs
on pretty much every computer
and every phone and
every little device
that's on the internet today.
So it's really, really popular.
In fact, we're going to start
with a simpler protocol that
is a reliable data
transport protocol that
isn't used between endpoints.
TCP is used between endpoints.
Now we're going to look
at a version of a protocol
that's a simple
version that actually
runs in every 802.11 device--
your laptop, phone,
and access points.
So we'll study that
protocol too first.
In the context of end to
end, between endpoints,
reliable data
transport, the problem
is the following-- you
have some network here.
It's a best-effort network
with those properties.
And what you want is you have
an application at one end.
And you have an
application at another end
running on some endpoints.
What this system
provides that we're
doing this study provides
is an abstraction where
you run software here--
you run software at this
end, and all of the stuff
sits on your end node.
This is your endpoint.
And the abstraction provides
some nice properties.
The application writes
some data in here
at the sender sending in.
So let's call this the sender.
And the other
guy's the receiver.
The application writes
stuff inside here.
The network is a
best-effort network.
And there's some protocol
between these two pieces
of software that make
sure that no matter what
the network does, what goes
up here into the application
is exactly the data
that was written
from this application in exactly
the same order in which it
was written.
So it provides reliable
and in-order delivery
of data, so reliable
and in order.
So every piece of
data that's written
shows up in exactly the
same order exactly once
at the receiver.
And these two ends
are called transport.
These two ends constitute
the transport layer.
And they [INAUDIBLE]
at the end points, OK?
So the application writes in
here, the transport protocol
delivers up to the application
stuff that's reliable
and in order.
And in particular, it
provides the semantics
that you can think of as
"exactly once" semantics.
In other words,
anything that's sent
is delivered exactly
once to the receiver,
and it's delivered in order.
Now, that's the abstraction
that TCP as well provides.
And that's the abstraction
of our 602 protocol.
It's reliable, in-order,
exactly-once delivery.
Now, there are other
implementations you can have.
There are protocols you could
have that provide reliability
but not in order.
So I'll give you all
the data that you send,
but it may show up
in different order,
and it's your problem to fix it.
Or you might provide a protocol
that provides in order,
but not reliable.
So if I'm doing real-time
video conferencing,
say, Skype, Skype
would probably want
to provide a protocol that's
in order but not reliable,
because if I speak, you'd
like to actually get
those things into the
Skype application in order.
But it's not really
required that it
be reliable because if a message
shows up, say, more than 100
or 200 milliseconds
after I spoke it,
it's going to distort
the conversation.
It's not going to be
intelligible to you.
And the human ear
is wonderful at--
the human brain is wonderful
at dealing with some clippiness
in the voice.
You know, occasional
packets get lost.
It's not the end of the world.
So there are lots of
interesting applications.
But in order is useful,
but not perfectly reliable.
Applications where reliable
is useful, but not perfectly
in order.
BitTorrent would be
an example of that.
An application where eventually
you want all of those movies
that you're trying to get.
But who cares what
order they come in?
You're not going to
start watching it
until the whole
file is assembled.
And so the protocol that
BitTorrent uses in effect--
it's a complicated protocol.
It's not point to point.
But in effect, it
provides reliability
without worrying about ordering.
So there's lots of combinations.
The combination we
care about is reliable,
in order, essentially giving
you the illusion that you have
a circuit between the
two endpoints, a wire
between the two endpoints, OK?
So is the abstraction clear?
Everyone understands what
we're trying to solve?
And in between this,
just think, there's
an adversary or some
network in the middle
that you sent
packets, and the thing
is just throwing packets away.
And every once in a while,
just for the heck of it,
it decides to delay a
packet for a long time.
And every once in
a while, it decides
to send packets along
different paths.
And your job is to
deal with all of that
and design the sending side
and the receiving sides
so that stuff still
shows up reliably
and in the same order
in which it was sent.
So we're going to try
to solve this problem.
We're going to solve it first
by coming up with a protocol.
It has a nice name to
it called stop and wait.
It's a very simple idea.
And this will be a protocol
that works, but it's slow.
But the good news is it works.
It's correct.
It gives the semantics we want.
And then we'll try to
improve its performance.
It's a very simple idea.
I'm sure you have-- just think
about this for three minutes.
You'll come up with something
that looks like this.
You just take the message you
want to send, whatever file,
stream, or video,
whatever it is,
and break it up into packets.
So far, there's
nothing new here.
The main first idea is we're
going to number every packet
with a sequence number.
So that's what's shown here as
"Data 1," "Data 2," "Data 3,"
and so forth.
So we're going to use a
sequence number on every packet.
Now, again, there are many ways
to implement sequence numbers.
The way that's the simplest
and most conceptually clean
is every packet has a
sequence number that
increments by 1 for every
subsequent packet that's sent.
And you might initially
start the sequence numbering
at 0 or 1 or whatever.
The sender and the receiver
have to agree on that.
Now, in reality, TCP
in the real world
is a little more complicated.
TCP provides sequence numbering
by numbering the bytes
with the byte offset
in the stream.
So if you send a packet
which is 25 bytes,
and the next packet
is 200 bytes,
the first packet is
going to have a sequence
number of, let's say, 0.
The second packet's going to
have a sequence number of 26
because it numbers the
starting of the byte offset.
But these are all details
that to first order,
we don't have to
really worry about.
The important point is
there is a sequence number.
And a sequence number
is a unique identifier
for the packet.
In other words, if I later send
a packet with the same sequence
number, I have to guarantee that
the material inside the packet
is the same as it was before.
So the assumption is that
this is a unique identifier
for the contents of the packet.
So it's a unique identifier.
We want to use it for
some other set of bytes.
We'll always use it again
for the same set of bytes
if we ever retransmit a packet
with the same sequence number.
When the receiver gets the
packet with a certain sequence
number, it does what
the post office does
if you send registered post--
you turn around, and you
send an acknowledgment.
And to allow the sender
to know which packet's
being acknowledged, you
stick in the sequence number
of the packet that's
being acknowledged.
So you send sequence 1.
Data 1, you get ACK 1.
Data 2, you get ACK 2, and
everything is wonderful.
It's easy, easy protocol.
So what happens when a packet's
lost, this data is lost?
What's going to
happen is the sender
is not going to get
an acknowledgment.
And after some period of
time called the timeout,
the sender decides that it
wants to retry that packet.
And it tries to
resend the packet.
And if it works, it
gets an acknowledgment.
When it gets that
acknowledgment,
that's when it goes and
sends the next packet.
So the property of
stop-and-wait protocol
is that you send a
packet only after you
get an acknowledgment.
You sent packet k plus
1 only after you get
an acknowledgment for packet k.
If you don't get an
acknowledgment for packet k,
you wait for a period of
time called a timeout.
And after that
timeout elapses, you
retransmit the packet that
you considered was lost,
that you thought was lost.
OK, simple.
Now, is this protocol reliable?
And when I ask
that question, you
have to assume that the network
may drop and reorder and do
whatever it does to packets.
But there's always a
non-zero probability
that a packet or data
packet or acknowledgment
packet sent on the network
has a non-zero probability
of reaching the other side.
Because if the probability
of packet loss is 1,
now no one can help us.
So is this protocol reliable?
OK.
Is this protocol in order?
It is in order in the way of--
I'm not actually describing
what the receiver does.
But I should tell you that
the receiver's semantics here
are when the receiver
gets the packet,
it delivers it to
the application.
Now, if you turn out that this
protocol is not necessarily
in order the way I described
it-- and I'll come back to why.
But so far, it looks like
the protocol is in order.
But remember what I
said about the receiver?
When the receiver
gets a data packet,
it delivers it up
to the application.
So is the protocol
potentially not in order?
It's not actually in order.
We'll get back to why.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just wondering
if the receiver
gets a data packet
and then tries to send
an acknowledgement back,
if the acknowledgement
gets wrong, I guess,
the sender will resend data.
Does the receiver then
compare to figure out?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Right,
so I haven't specified that.
And you are one step ahead of--
you're at the next picture here.
What happens in this case?
You get a duplicate packet.
And in fact, that's
precisely for this reason
that this protocol
is not actually--
it's kind of in
order, but in order
means that you deliver packets
in the same order in which they
were sent.
And in the way I've
described the description,
given the description
of this protocol,
this protocol does not provide
exactly one semantics, right?
It provides at
least one semantics.
In other words, every package
is delivered at least once
to the application.
And what you would like us to
deliver every packet exactly
once to the
application in order.
So what would you have to do
at the receiver in the software
that you write and the receiver
transport to take the same idea
and make it be a reliable,
in-order, exactly-once
protocol?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Loop up if you
received that sequence number.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Sorry, say again.
AUDIENCE: Look up if you've
received that sequence number.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Look up if we
AUDIENCE: I think that's right.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Good.
So one implementation
is you perhaps keep
track of all the sequence
numbers you've ever
received and delivered
up to the application.
If the new guy
comes in, you look
and see if it's in your
list, and deliver it if not.
You could do better.
You have to do all that work.
You have to keep track of
the list of all the sequence
numbers you've ever received
in order for this protocol
to work.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah,
is it enough to keep track
of simply the very last
one you've delivered
and also guarantee that you'll
only deliver stuff in order?
So if you get up to packet
number 17 and you now get 18,
you deliver it up
to the application
and update your counter
to be set from 17 to 18
of the last sequence
number you've delivered.
If your last sequence number
delivered in order is 17,
and you get 16, throw it out.
If you get 17, you throw it out.
If you get anything-- if you
get 19, which probably shouldn't
happen in this
protocol unless there's
a mistake in the implementation
that they're sending in,
if the last sequence
number I got was 17,
can the sender send 19?
AUDIENCE: No.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Why not?
AUDIENCE: Because we have 17
acknowledgements [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Because-- that's right.
So unless there's a bug in
either side of implementation,
which, trust me, when
you implement it,
you'll probably end
up having some bugs,
and you'd know
something is amiss.
But there are these
invariants that have to hold.
The sender can send k plus 1
only if it gets an ACK for k.
The sender gets an ACK for k
only if the receiver got k.
And therefore, if the sender's
last in-order sequence number
received and delivered
the application was 17,
it can't actually get a 19 in a
correctly implemented protocol.
But if it does, because
in the real world,
you don't know who the heck
wrote the sending side.
You might have
done your receiver,
and the sender might
have been done by,
oh, I don't know, Microsoft.
And it may have an issue with
it, or Apple, or whoever.
I mean, you don't want
to trust it, right?
So you have to be careful about
making sure that you might
want to assume the protocols--
you don't want
assume necessarily
that the other guys implemented
the protocol right because he
might not have.
And so, who knows
what might happen?
So your rule as the
receiver is to rigidly obey
whatever the discipline
is, which is you deliver up
a packet exactly in order.
OK, so we wanted
exactly-once semantics.
And the way you get
that is you get that
by keeping track of the
very last sequence number
that you received.
So this protocol-- so the
first idea is sequence numbers.
The second protocol is a
retransmission after a timeout.
Now, how big should
this timeout be?
This whole protocol rests
on this magic timeout.
What should it be?
15, 17?
What are the units
of the timeout?
Actually, what are the
units of this timeout?
It's time.
So it's, like, seconds or
milliseconds or something.
How big should it be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: What?
AUDIENCE: 5 milliseconds.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
5 milliseconds?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
milliseconds.
AUDIENCE: Units
[INAUDIBLE] milliseconds.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah, units
are seconds or milliseconds.
Good.
But how would you pick it?
AUDIENCE: You know
the round-trip time.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: OK, good.
So that's a good idea.
There's this thing I've
written on the left called
the round-trip time.
But you don't know
the round-trip time,
but you could measure
the round-trip time.
And I'll talk about how you
measure it a little bit later.
But it's important to realize
that if you make the timeout be
smaller than the
round-trip time,
where the round-trip time is
defined as the time at which
you sent a packet to when you
got an acknowledgment for that
packet--
if you make the timeout smaller
than the round-trip time,
what happens in this protocol?
Let me first ask, is the
protocol still correct?
By correct, I mean,
does it provide
reliable, in-order delivery?
OK, it's correct, because
that correctness does not rest
on how we pick the timeout.
However, what is the problem
with making the timeout smaller
than round-trip time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah, if this
protocol's going to be here,
you're going to
be retransmitting
and retransmitting and using
up a lot more of the network's
resources than you need to in
order for you to actually get
your protocol to work correctly.
And you might, if the time
out is really, really small,
you would probably
congest the network.
OK, so the timeout
has to be bigger
than the round-trip time.
The trouble in a
packet-switched network
is that delays are variable
in a best-effort network.
And, in fact, packets
may be reordered.
There may be weird things
going on in the network, which
means that the round-trip times
are actually not constant.
They vary with time.
They vary with other traffic.
They vary with lots
of other factors.
And so what you want is
an adaptive method that
would measure the
round-trip time,
estimate the round-trip
time, and then come up
with some sort of an
algorithm to compute or to set
the timeout as a function
of the observations
of the round-trip time.
I'll get back to
that later on today.
And we'll also talk about
this in recitation tomorrow.
It's actually a very nice
application of a very simple
low-pass filter.
So we'll actually come
back to this idea.
But what I want to you
to have in your head
right now is this idea
that there's a timeout.
And the timeout has to
be-- which I'll call
RTO for Retransmission TimeOut.
We have this idea that
our retransmission timeout
has to be bigger than
the round-trip time, OK?
So what I need to
tell you still is
how to measure and estimate
the round-trip time
and how to use these estimates
of the round-trip time
to pick the timeout.
But let's subcontract
that problem to someone.
Let's say that there's
the black box that
will tell you what
the timeout should be,
and now you have this protocol.
So assuming we have that black
box and someone telling you
the retransmission timeout,
what I would like to do now
is to spend some
time telling you
how well this protocol works.
I'd like to understand what
is the throughput, which
is the data rate that
you get if you're
on the stop-and-wait protocol.
So that's what I
want to do now--
throughput of stop and wait.
So the input here is--
I'm going to assume a
very, very simple model.
I'm going to assume for a
minute that the round-trip time
doesn't change a whole lot.
This is a very
simplifying assumption,
but there's some
average round-trip time.
I'm going to assume that
the round-trip time is RTT.
The same result holds
if the round-trip time
varies, but just simple model.
Let's just assume the
round-trip time is fixed.
And let's assume that
somebody tells us what
the retransmission timeout is.
And I need one more parameter.
I'm going to assume that I
know the network's packet loss
rate because intuitively,
if the network's packet loss
rate is zero--
that is, no packets are lost.
No data packets, no
acknowledgments are lost--
then you would
expect this protocol
has higher throughput than
if packets were lost, right?
If the packet loss
rate is 50%, you
would expect that
what would happen
is, well, half the packets
or ACKs are getting lost,
which means you have to
retransmit the packet.
And every time you
retransmit the packet,
the protocol comes to a wait.
And you have to wait
until the timeout happens.
So the bigger the
packet loss rate,
you would expect the
protocol to be slower.
So I'm going to assume
that we have RTT and RTO.
And we have a packet loss rate
of L. So what does that mean?
What it means is that if I
send a large number of packets
to the network, a fraction,
L, of them will get lost.
And I'll just assume in
the simplifying model
that the packet losses
are independent.
So they're sort of
Bernoulli losses.
You know, every packet
gets lost independently
with some probability.
Now, I also will assume
in this protocol--
does it matter to the
performance of the protocol
if the data packet is lost
or if the ACK packet is lost?
It doesn't matter.
As far as the sender's-- and
this is an important point
to understand.
As far as the
sender is concerned,
if a timeout happens,
it has no way
of knowing whether
the timeout happened
because the data was lost
or because the ACK was lost.
This is, like, absolutely--
the receiver knows.
Or actually, the
receiver doesn't
know if a timeout
happened, but the receiver
does know whether it got
a data packet or not.
But the sender-- the
only thing it's acting on
is the absence of an ACK.
And the absence of an
ACK indicates either
that the data was lost
or that the ACK was lost,
and it has no idea which.
Therefore, we could
assume for this analysis
that this packet loss
rate of L is actually
a bidirectional
packet loss rate.
What I mean by that is L is the
probability that either a data
packet is lost, or
its ACK was lost, OK?
Now, if I give you the
one-way loss probability,
you can do the calculation.
That's a probability
calculation to find out
what is the probability that
either the packet was lost
or the data was lost.
That's an easy calculation.
But let me just assume that
the probability that either
the packet was lost, data packet
was lost, or its ACK was lost,
is L.
So given these numbers,
what I want to do is,
given these things, I want to
know what the throughput is.
In other words, how
many packets per second
am I transmitting, am
I able to transmit,
or am I able to receive
at the receiver?
So if you want to look at
what happens in this picture,
if you draw time like that--
you send a packet, and
maybe you get an ACK here.
So D1, A1.
You send D2 immediately.
And you get A2 after some time.
And maybe you have a timeout.
So you send D3.
And then you have a period
of time, which is the RTO.
No ACK happens.
You send D3 again.
And maybe no ACK
happens for a while.
You have another RTO.
I'll assume that the
RTO was fixed here.
And you send D3 again.
And you get an ACK here.
And then you send D4
here, and so forth, right?
That's an example of what could
happen in a particular time
evolution of the protocol.
What I mean by
throughput is that I
would like to run such
an experiment for a very
long time, or run many,
many such experiments, which
is sort of equivalent to
running an experiment for a very
long time, and then count how
many packets did I successfully
get at the receiver.
Or equivalently,
I can ask how many
ACKs did I get at the sender
over that long experiment,
right?
And the number of ACKs that
I get at the center divided
by the time of that experiment
will tell me the number
of packets per second.
Or put another way, if
I run the experiment
for some long period
of time, and I
receive n packets coming back--
right?
If I receive n acknowledgments--
and if the expected
time here between when
I send a data packet--
I send a data packet.
I get an ACK.
I send a data packet,
and I get an ACK.
If I take the expected
value of that time--
that is, the expected time
between when I send a packet
and one I get an ACK--
the 1 over that number,
1 over the expected time,
is equal to my throughput
in packets per second.
Because if I run the
experiment for a long time,
I'm going to get some
number of acknowledgments.
So if I run it for
some period of time
where n times e of t--
where e of t is number here,
and I get back an
acknowledgment,
n divided by n times e
of t is my throughput.
And therefore, 1 over
the expected time
is the throughput of
my experiment, right?
So this should be intuitive,
because what's really happening
is, with a little
bit of handwaving,
actually, that I send data.
I get an ACK.
Send data, I get an ACK.
There's a certain
expected amount of time,
so I will send 1 over that
packets per second, OK?
So in other words,
the throughput
is the reciprocal of
the expected amount
of time between
when I send a packet
and when I get an
acknowledgment.
So it's enough for us
to compute the expected
value of this time, right, or
the mean value of that time.
All right, so we could do that
calculation in a simpler way.
There's the sort of
tedious way to do it,
and there's a very
simple, nice way to do it.
So we want to calculate expected
time between data and ACK.
And one way to do
this is to say that--
let's say I send a data packet.
One of two things can happen.
I either get an ACK for it,
or I don't get an ACK for it.
What's the probability that
if I send a data packet,
I get an ACK for it?
Well, the probability
that I send a packet
and I don't get an ACK
for it is L. Therefore,
the probability that if I send
a data packet, I get ACK for it,
is 1 minus L, right?
So with probability 1 minus
L, I send a data packet,
and I immediately
get-- and when I say
"immediately," I get an ACK
for that data packet, right?
And how long does that take?
If I get an ACK for it,
the ACK comes back to me
in a time which is equal to
RTT, the Round-Trip Time, right?
So therefore, I can write a
formula that looks like this.
I can write this
expected time which
I'm trying to calculate as
being equal to 1 minus L.
With probability 1 minus L,
the expected time between when
I send a data packet
and when I get an ACK
for it is equal
to the RTT, right?
Because 1 minus L is, by
definition, the probability
that I send a packet
and I get an ACK for it.
Send a data packet
and get an ACK.
Now, what happens
with probability L?
With probability L,
I send a data packet,
and I don't get an ACK for it.
So now I want to compute
the expected time given
that I don't get an ACK for it.
The first thing
that has to happen
is I need to take a timeout.
So I have to wait for a period
of time shown in this picture
given by the RTO.
And then once I
wait for that RTO,
and I now start
by sending a data
packet, the expected
amount of time
before I get an ACK
for that data packet
is exactly equal to the
original expected time
that I'm trying to
calculate, right?
Because it doesn't matter
what happened in the past.
Let's say I take a timeout.
And now, I come back
here and [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm not going to
send a data packet.
What's the expected time
before I get an ACK?
Well, that's exactly
equal to the same answer
that we're trying to calculate,
this expected time over here.
Therefore, I could write this
recursion type of relationship.
The expected time is 1 minus
L the RTT plus L times the RTO
plus the same expected time that
I'm trying to calculate, right?
What this says is with
probably 1 minus L,
the time it'll take for me to
get an ACK is equal to the RTT.
And with probability L, it's
equal to-- first of all,
this RTO--
I have to wait for that
retransmission timeout.
And then once I do that, well,
I have to add some more time.
And that time that I
have to add is exactly
equal to the same expected
time from the left-hand side
that I'm trying to calculate.
Does this makes sense?
You could kind of do this
in a more tedious way.
You could say, well, with
probability 1 minus L,
my time is RTT.
With probability
L times 1 minus L,
the time is equal
to RTT plus RTO.
With probability L
squared times 1 minus L,
this is, like, two losses.
And then a
retransmission-- the time
is 2 times the RTO plus RTT.
With probability LQ times
1 minus L, it's that.
If you do all of that stuff,
you'll get the same thing.
But this is the more--
there's a simpler way to do it.
So if you run take the
expected time over to one side
and solve this equation,
what you'll end up with
is that the expected time is
equal to RTT plus L over 1
minus L times the RTO.
I mean, as the packet loss
rate becomes larger and larger
and larger, this term
starts to dominate
because L over 1 minus L
starts to be bigger and bigger
and bigger, which is
what you would expect.
If the directional packet
loss rate is large,
you'd expect the RTO terms
to start to dominate,
and the expected time is
larger and larger and larger.
If the packet loss rate is
zero, then the expected time
is exactly equal to the RTT.
You send a packet.
You get an ACK.
And with an RTT, you
send the next packet.
You get an ACK.
And of course, the throughput's
equal to 1 over the expected
time.
That's the reciprocal of
the expected time, OK?
Now, what's the best case here?
The best case here
is that you get
one packet per round-trip time.
The worst case is
arbitrarily back depending
on the packet loss rate.
But the important point here
is that even in the best case,
you're able to send only
one packet, at most,
one packet per round-trip time.
The question is,
how good or bad is
one packet per round-trip time?
Is this clear, this
intuition behind why
this is one packet per
round-trip time in the best
case?
That should be pretty
obvious, right?
I send a packet.
I get an ACK.
Send a packet.
This calculation just shows
a little bit more detail
about what happens when the
packet loss rate's non-zero.
So if the packet loss
rate is, say, 20%,
you take 1/5 over 4/5.
So it's RTT plus 1/4 of
the retransmission timeout.
That's what it says
the expected time is.
And 1 over that is throughput.
Now, how bad or
good-- is it clear?
Any questions?
OK, so now, how good or bad
is this 1 over the round trip
time?
So let's say that you have a
network between Boston to--
I don't know-- San Francisco.
And if you do these pings
or whatever, let's--
I mean, I don't know
the real numbers,
but let's say it's
80 milliseconds.
Just for the calculation
to be easier,
let's assume it's
100 milliseconds.
And let's say that a
packet on the internet it's
about 10,000 bits.
So let's make it bytes.
Let's say that it's
1,000, say, 1,500 bytes.
So what this says is
that the throughput
that I would get with the
stop-and-wait protocol
if I ran it on
this internet path
would be 1,500 bytes
divided by 100 milliseconds.
So that's 15,000 bytes per
second, 15 kilobytes a second,
which might have been
really, really good in 1985,
but no one's going to be
happy with this today.
I mean, you might have
a link that's a megabyte
a second or a gigabyte a
second or 10-- you know,
bigger than that.
But no matter how fast
the network links are,
this protocol is
completely dominated
by the delay or the latency,
the round-trip latency,
between the sender
and the receiver.
And you end up with a throughput
that's pegged to a small value.
And so, people don't like that.
So question is, how
can you do better?
What can you do now
to this protocol?
Or come up with a new
method, a new protocol
that would improve the
throughput of this system.
Because if people pay
money for network links,
they'd like to actually get
higher performance from it.
So what could you do?
AUDIENCE: Larger packets?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: What?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Larger packets.
Well, yeah, larger packets is--
yeah, why don't we
make our packets
as big as the five
we want to send?
Actually, I digress.
Why don't we make
packets really big?
Like, I got a megabyte file
or a gigabyte file to send.
Why do I have to break it
up into smaller packets?
AUDIENCE: Larger packets
use more bandwidth?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Well, to send the data,
no matter if we break
it up small or big,
you're going to use
the same bandwidth.
I mean, that's a good question.
Yeah, you have an answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] how
to [INAUDIBLE] over time.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
That's kind of true.
You know, if a
packet is, you know,
let's say a gigabyte file
you want to transmit.
And you send that
in one atomic unit,
and goes through four
hops in the network,
and then it gets dropped
on the first hop,
you end up having to send
an entire gigabyte again
over all those other hops.
That's actually not good.
But in fact, really
large packets
are probably a bad
idea even for networks
which don't drop any packets.
I mean, think of the case when
I have a gigabyte file to send,
and you have a
gigabyte file to send.
The problem if you make
these packets really big
is that one of us is-- on a
shared link, only one of us
can send that packet, which
means the other guy is going
to be waiting a really,
really long time for him
to send that packet.
So the reason why, in the
end, packets are modest size
has to do with our wanting
to share the network evenly
over smaller time scales.
It's because we want to give
fairness across smaller time
scales, allowing
everybody who's competing
access to the network.
So even if we have big
amounts of data to send,
we prefer to break them
up into smaller chunks
among other reasons,
one reason being
we don't want to start
other connections
and prevent them from
gaining access to the network
because there's some huge
transfer sitting in front.
So that's part of the reason.
So anyway, so bigger packets
doesn't quite cut it.
So what else could you do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to send.
So if you cannot [INAUDIBLE].
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: OK,
you know, well, I'll
come back to this on Monday.
That's actually a
really good idea.
But when would you
stop for 8, 16, 32?
I mean, at some
point, this is like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] at some
point, it's going to tail.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Because packets are lost.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so you go back.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: OK,
this is a really good idea.
We're not actually going to
teach that here in this course.
This is actually what
TCP does in the beginning
of the connection.
But before we-- what
else could you do?
That's a good idea.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could
send a fixed number.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah,
you could do a fixed number.
You know, somebody could pick--
I actually kind of--
it is a really good
idea to do 1, 2, 4, 8.
And then if it fails, you come
back down to, say, 1 or 1/2
of whatever worked the last time
and then continue from that.
That particular thing
has a name to it.
That protocol is
called slow start.
It's ironic because
it's really fast.
It's exponential,
right-- 1, 2, 4, 8.
But yet, it's called slow start.
I'll probably tell you
more about it on Wednesday.
But we'll ease
into that solution.
We'll do something simpler.
We'll use something called
a sliding window protocol
with a fixed-size window.
You just make that 1
be 7 or 4 or 6 or 8.
I'll tell you later next time
how you pick that value, OK?
And one way to pick that
value is to do it dynamically
like the gentleman
in the front said.
It's more complicated.
But let's just pick
a fixed-size value.
So the idea is actually
very, very simple.
Now that I have one
packet outstanding.
We use this idea in
computer science.
We use this over
and over again--
pipelining.
So you just send
multiple of them
and have multiple
outstanding packets.
By "outstanding," I mean
a packet that hasn't yet
been acknowledged.
A data packet that hasn't
yet been acknowledged
is called an
outstanding data packet.
And you have multiple
of these outstanding.
And every time you
get an acknowledgment,
you send one more packet.
So that's shown in this
timeline here, right?
So you start here.
You send a packet.
I don't know why
this isn't working.
Ah, there we go.
You send a packet.
You get an acknowledgment.
When you get an acknowledgment,
you send another packet.
Get an acknowledgment.
You send another packet.
But in the meantime, there are
these other acknowledgments
coming in.
And the rule is very
simple-- every time
you get an acknowledgment that
you have not seen before, send
the next packet in sequence.
So the sender just keeps sending
packets in sequence order.
Every time it gets
an acknowledgment
that it hasn't seen
before for a packet
that it had sent before, it
sends the next incrementing
sequence number.
So this painstaking
animation will
attempt to show you that,
assuming it's correct.
So the window here
is five packets, OK?
I'll tell you later
some guidelines on how
to pick this window size.
But this number
of packets here is
called the window, the number
of outstanding packets,
or the number of
unacknowledged packets.
It's always going to be 5.
It's going to be
5 in this example.
It's always going to be a fixed
value in our protocol, OK?
So you send the first packet.
When you get an acknowledgment
for that first packet,
you slide the window forward
by 1, and you send packet 6.
When you get an
acknowledgment for a packet 2,
you slide the window forward,
and you send packet 7.
When you get an
acknowledgment for 3,
you slide the window forward,
and you send packet 8.
This is-- sorry?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it appears
[INAUDIBLE] out of order.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
That's a good question.
I'll get to that in a moment.
The answer is that the sender's
rule is always the same.
Yes, you get acknowledgments
out of order.
As long as it's an
acknowledgment for a packet--
sorry, as long as
it's an acknowledgment
that you have not seen
before for a packet
that you have actually sent, you
slide the window forward by 1
and send a new packet, OK?
And you keep track of the
fact that you received
an acknowledgment, so you
know that you should never
retransmit that packet.
I want to define this
thing and pause here.
I want you to understand
the definition of a window
and internalize it.
If the window size
is W, what it means
is that the maximum number of
unacknowledged packets that you
can have in the connection is
W. There are many different ways
of defining a window.
In fact, TCP inside
it has two windows.
This definition is
one of those windows.
I won't talk about the
second definition here.
I'll get to it next week.
It's not important
for us right now.
So again, to repeat, if
the window size is W,
it means that the maximum
number of unacknowledged packets
in the system in the protocol
is W. So the rule of the sender
is going to be to very
religiously adhere
to this rule.
In other words, every time
it gets an acknowledgment,
it waits and sees whether
it's an acknowledgment
for a packet it has sent before
that it has not seen before.
If you get an
acknowledgment like that,
it means that some
packet has been received,
which means you can get rid
of that packet from the stack
of unacknowledged packets that
you have and send a new packet.
Because you can
send a new packet
because you know that the
number of unacknowledged packets
reduced by 1 because you
got an ACK, which means
you can now send
a new packet, OK?
It's a very simple
rule if you just
follow that idea to implement.
It also is surprisingly
easy to get wrong.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the window
doesn't necessarily
have to be consecutive?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: The window
doesn't have to be consecutive.
This is a really,
really good point.
And it's very
tempting to implement
a window that's consecutive.
And you'll find that after a
while, if you follow that idea,
and you do it wrongly, the
protocol will just stall.
And every time,
there's about a quarter
of the students, the first
time they implemented this,
it just stops
working after a while
as the packet loss rates grow.
So it's important that
in this definition
of the protocol in the
way it's defined here,
the window of
unacknowledged packets--
it's not necessarily
consecutive.
So you could have packets 1, 2,
3, 4, 8, 9, 10, 11 outstanding
if your window size is 8.
The other guys may have
gotten acknowledged.
That's absolutely true, yes.
OK?
All right, now what
happens under all
these other weird cases that
are going to happen here?
So let me first
show you a timeline
of how a timeout is dealt with.
So let's say in this
case, the window size is
5 again like it was before.
So everything is going
wonderfully well here.
And let's say now you move on.
You send packets 6, 7, 8.
And let's say packet 8 is lost.
What the sender is going to do
is it's going to send packet 9.
It's going to send packet 10
based on acknowledgments for 4
and 3 that it received before.
So, sorry, when it
got acknowledgment 3,
it sent packet 8.
8 was lost.
The sender didn't know
that at this point.
When it got an acknowledgment
for 4, it sends 9.
for 5, it sends 10.
When it gets an
acknowledgment for 6,
it goes ahead and sends 11.
When it gets an
acknowledgment for 7,
it goes ahead and sends 12.
So at this point,
the sender actually
has outstanding 12,
11, 10, 9, 8, OK?
Now, at some point,
it discovers that--
in fact, this picture continues.
In this picture, what happened
is that you sent out 9.
You've got an
acknowledgment for 9.
And at that point,
you send out 13
because whenever you
get an acknowledgment,
you send out the next
consecutive packet
you should be sending out.
So at this point
in time, the sender
has a bunch of
outstanding packets in it,
and it's got acknowledgment.
And this is an interesting
case because packet 8 was lost.
9 was sent later, and
9 got acknowledged.
But we still haven't
timed out on 8.
So at this point in time,
the outstanding packets
in the window are 13,
12, 11, 10, and 8,
giving you that nonconsecutive
observation that you notice.
And then at some point in time,
based on the round-trip time,
based on the black
box, the guy timed out,
and 8 got retransmitted.
And then 8 got retransmitted.
You got an acknowledgment for
8, and the protocol sort of
continues in that fashion.
Does this makes sense?
So it's actually not that
hard when you think about it.
What the sender does is
a very simple idea, which
is every time it gets a new
acknowledgment for a packet it
had sent before but hadn't seen
an acknowledgment for before,
it just goes ahead and
sends the next packet.
And then it has a
separate process by which
it maintains this timeout.
And whenever an
acknowledgment does not
arrive within a
timeout, it goes ahead
and retransmits that back.
Now, when it
retransmits the packet,
the assumption here is
that the original packet
was actually lost.
So the timeout has
to be bigger than--
for the system to
work well, the timeout
has to be bigger
than the maximum time
that a packet can sit
around in the system.
So if the timeout is too small,
and you retransmit 8 too early,
it could be that 8 is
not lost, but 8 is just
being reordered in the network
and going on some very long
circulous path.
You know, I recently read
that someone got a letter
in New York 70 years--
it was sent in 1943, and it
showed up, like, two weeks ago.
So, I mean, it could
happen on the internet too.
I mean, quite literally, if
you're on an Amtrak train,
and you're using their
wireless network,
some packets come to you
in 300 or 400 milliseconds,
which is arguably very long.
But literally, there
are packets that
will come back to you a
minute after you sent them--
reach the receiver a
minute after you sent them.
And they could be out of order.
So in fact, this is my
student's, and I call
this the great Amtrak network.
It's really good
because it gives us
really interesting research
for others to work on.
But the people who
are on that train
probably-- it's miserable.
So anyway, this could happen.
But, and so, the
timeout is a heuristic.
It could be that 8 was
retransmitted wrongly
in a spurious way.
But our hope is that if
the timeout is long enough,
it could be that--
if the timeout's
long enough, the idea
is that you retransmit 8
because the original 8 was lost.
And now the outstanding
packets in the window
are 8, 13, 12, 11, and 10.
But the 8 here is not
that 8, but this 8.
But as long as the
contents of 8 are the same,
it doesn't matter which 8 it is.
But of course, if the timeout
is too small, there are two 8's
sitting in the network.
And now you actually have more
than W packets in the window.
But as far as the
sender is concerned,
it has exactly those
8, 10, 11, 12, and 13.
It's true that there's one more
packet if the timeout happened
too early.
That's the network's problem.
As far as the
sender is concerned,
it has five outstanding packets.
The receiver is a little
trickier than in the other case
because what it has to do--
I mean, it's trickier in
that it has to maintain
a buffer of packets.
So the receiver has a
little more of a job to do.
In the previous
stop-and-wait protocol,
any time it got an
out-of-order packet,
it's probably because the sender
is badly implemented, right?
If the last sequence number
I deliver to the application
was 17, and I got
a 19, it's a bug.
Whereas here, is
the last sequence
number I delivered to
the application is 17,
and I get a 19, it means
that, well, there's a window.
And maybe 18 was lost, or who
knows what happened, right?
Maybe 18 will show up later.
So the receiver now
has an interesting job.
And this is important
because when
you implement this stuff in
this protocol [INAUDIBLE],,
you've got to make sure that
whenever you deliver packets
from the receiver protocol
to the application,
you deliver it in order and
update the last sequence
number you delivered, OK?
So that's important to do.
But if you do that
and then acknowledge
a packet when it's
received, just
send an acknowledgment for it.
The protocol will continue,
and it will work well.
So this is what
you'll be looking
at in the lab, the piece
that's going to go out today.
This is the last lab.
And then on tomorrow
in recitation,
we'll look at how the
timeout is selected.
And then on Monday,
I'll talk more
about an analysis
of this protocol.